it is a crime it's not terrorist is
going to show America its urban public
education if we don't do something about
it I don't know where the money is
coming the equipment is destroyed
there's graffiti everywhere the teacher
tells the parent oh this is a good
school when I said lady your kid can't
read or add two and two what do you mean
it's a good school hi I'm Nicolas before
reasontv we're talking to Bob Bowden
about his great new movie the cartel
about school choice bob thanks for
talking to us she ain't been here what
what is the message of the cartel waste
and corruption in public schools is
rampant there's a general misconception
people of vote for higher education
budgets because of they have sympathy
towards teacher salaries I think
teachers should make more money what
they are professionals well that's what
deserve to be paid like professionals
that's right oftentimes they don't
realize that what they're really voting
for are more patronage jobs more
administration and more contractors more
spending that doesn't affect the
classroom so what is the solution to
that that you offer at the cartel school
choice basically the idea is that you
have some consequences to failure in
education which we don't right now
particularly in in urban areas where
people don't have the money for private
school or the money to move which is a
soft form of school choice what you know
most people who have kids in schools
will rate their school district or a
particular school you know eighty
percent it's great or better than great
so how do you actually motivate people
to embrace a you know a choice system
well first of all where we're seeing
about your programs passing across the
country are in the worst urban areas
where those parents are already highly
motivated the one the ones who are at
least are engaged enough to be aware the
problem and I think that is in other
words the the first step the first kind
of you know foot in the door of more
choices going forward so but that said
you also look at the taxes people are
paying into school systems which are in
many places you know not just growing
out of control but the the bad economy
we've had recently has you know with
people getting laid off and
the housing bubble bursting has made the
tax burden more onerous so it's so
motivating you know a lot of people one
of the main criticisms of school choices
that you know lower-income people like
you know they just can't make good
decisions how do you worry about that
well then maybe we shouldn't let them
make any decisions you know why do why
do they pick doctors you know why do
they pick not anymore well why do they
pick what food they eat why do they put
you know like it's preposterous you know
and the fact is is you can you know
there's like a there's a moral argument
here to make where if the kid is too we
have over fifty percent dropout rates in
New York la Detroit Denver Houston all
occurred all across the country these
major cities you know with dropout rates
sometimes in Detroit it's more like 75
percent and so you know you look at any
international comparison the United
States is at the bottom of the large
industrial scale even as it pays much
more than average we spend the most and
do the worst do that's right I don't
know that seems right to me how did you
get interested in in the school choice
argument well I'd been a TV reporter
uncovered a cup of stories over the
years and become the first one I
remember doing was on tenure you
basically never fire or bad teacher in
almost every skin most school districts
you get lifetime tenure the first day of
your third or fourth year that's right
yeah that's right so you know I just
remember being dumb founded by this
revelation would you which it was a
revelation to me that you know really
you could never be fun unless you commit
a felony run it by the age of 24 25 you
have a guaranteed job the rest of your
life you could be late you know the
laziest person but what small business
person would announce to their staff you
know hey all of you have been working
for me for three years I hope you keep
working but if you don't just know
you'll never be fired ever it would sits
madness so I started as a TV reporter
doing that and then finally I had a
friend who got a job in an inner city
high school as an English teacher I
started hearing her stories of what it
was like on a daily basis and I thought
I don't think a lot of people know their
stuff what what has been the reception
for the cartel which is I mean you're
you're rolling it out to different
cities around the country and what not
well some people love it and some people
hate it you know it's certainly evokes
reactions from from the other side in
other words as well so that you know
there were people that are just made
indignant by it and all we do basically
show newspaper stories we show websites
directly almost everything in the movie
is you know the source material is
visually is visually shown so I think
some of them have a hard time you know
hey think if thinking of reasons to hate
it when you see that we show janitors
making six figures in public schools we
show superintendence making four hundred
and seventy thousand dollars for one
year and was the same year they were
fired because they were incompetent but
they made 47 470,000 a 30 million dollar
football field in a school with eighty
five percent failing academics and and
this is how they spend a billion dollars
disappearing in the school construction
corporation a department so there's you
know they get frustrated off and buy it
but you know that's what's needed have
you in making the movie and and then
rolling it out what have you it has
anything surprise you something that you
didn't expect to understand or agree
with her well I would say the amount of
money that defining our finding out a
billion dollars disappeared and not one
person arrested where was in jail this
is in new jersey new jersey school
construction corporation it was
dumbfounded to me also but so the amount
of money but i would also say that when
I've been to some of these worst
inner-city areas with you know really
dysfunctional dropout factory schools
and then you go visit a well-run charter
school in that same place and it wanted
you want to cry these kids are so sweet
and well behaved and smart and learning
and engaged you know we've been told
yeah but these these kids can't learn
you know and you just find out it's just
not true at all and so that that that
was really i think profound a little bit
to me you know there was there was a i
don't know i was somewhat poignant to be
in those place to see the disparities in
that with the same population what's
your next project um reasontv no I
I don't really I'm still live rolling in
a job and I don't I don't have a next
one right now continued good luck I mean
it's a story that needs to be told
there's none question so for reason TV
i'm nick gillespie we've been talking
with Bob Bowden of the the director and
the eminence behind the cartel and
excellent movie about school choice